I think I just still I just pulled out a
YouTube video I scheduled a YouTube
video for 1:30 Central Time which is
right now well I'm playing LVN 2k
I'll be on 2k probably like timed it so
I plan on splitting like c3 yeah look at
this this no views uploaded 32 seconds
ago also look at this close anyway okay
let's focus on chess I'm gonna play e3
is my new kind of pets opening I have a
story behind this waiting for d5 yeah d5
okay so the story behind this there's a
few layers to it I'll play queen h5 as a
very rare variation but be g7 thanks for
subbing for 6 months
so I don't want to admit this but I was
watching I was watching one of excuses
chess videos and he was playing VR chess
and he had now slipped III meaning to
play efore and then I think he played
Knight c3 and I reminded me of this
variation which I discovered like a year
or two ago
bhasu thanks for solving our thanks for
gifting a son and Charles thinks with a
hundred bits now xqc didn't go into this
line but a few years ago I remember just
having like a random conversation with a
former teammates from Webster University
a grandmaster Alex Alexander Shimano and
he was just like in casual conversation
just mentioned this line the fact that
like can play queen h5 on move to
followed by Bishop b5 that's really
annoying for black to deal with because
it's not clear how black defends upon
because f6 is not possible g6 of course
gets forts bishop t satin loses this
pawn Bishop d6 loses his pawn so that's
already like already under a lot of
pressure
and it was a bit funny that like xqc was
the one who who triggered the memory
have to find the video but like when he
Mouse slipped III he just started saying
bad words so I was ashamed last night
I was trying to get this but no one was
playing he 5 D 5 so Queen D 6 was the
best move and now I have to remember
what to do I think it's uh yeah Knight
f3 like just keep applying pressure now
I have 3 pieces developed actually four
pieces developed all targeting the
center it's a fascinating opening a very
weird name asking is this a secret
opening prep I was talking about yes it
should still be a secret so everyone
watching don't tell anyone else oh did
the pitch change
I have noise suppression because
sometimes the fridge likes to make
noises Oh your lips are sealed
ok that's good yeah don't don't clip it
so I don't want to suggest any like good
moves for black but very often like can
continue adding pressure of d4 and these
pawns are under under massive fire only
500 people will know about it until I
upload it to youtube and then yeah if
you're watching in the future on YouTube
you should also keep the secret my
opponent has a long time to think though
or just a long time to suffer like f6 is
not possible actually how does what does
black defend the pawn because this move
gives away the d4 square or even allows
95 attacking multiple things
hey it's Charles gifting their first sub
gifting a tier 1 sub 2 diamond cutter
thanks so much and thanks diamond cutter
being a longtime mod yeah the the choker
Cup is in six days I'll be playing some
guy named Hikaru I have to get revenge
he beat me last time and then he also
he's beating me so many times
at least in chess but I'll try and
prepare well the 100,000th sub get I
don't know I don't even know if I can
like see because some people don't share
publicly that they subscribe so it would
be a little bit hard to see but we're
eighteen away so the question is well
this game finish before reaching 100,000
not sure yeah so waiting waiting for for
black to move there should be seven I've
taken with a pawn I I really shouldn't
say so I don't know if my phone is
watching the stream also yeah we're also
celebrating 40,000 followers from twitch
which was also hit like I think a few
hours ago so thanks everyone I do really
appreciate the the support over the
weeks months and years
how do you prep for choker meditation
and sleep and also yeah also playing a
bit so I tried to I tried to direct
people from this YouTube video to the
livestream
so maybe what I'll do as a shameless
plug on my own video while my opponents
thinking let's um let's go into this
video ads actually ads are not
necessarily bad oh wait it says 100k but
it round it up we're still at some
number so let's comment I'm streaming
now watch live I'm sure a lot of people
will ask up on it moved Oh free pawn
could take with Queen or night I'll take
with Queen
yeah I'm happy to trade Queens if I mop
upon it stick okay that was an opening
success traded Queens one upon I could
take here maybe D for D for looks looks
like a centralizing move
thanks for something big fo and Bob
Valentin me um is copying my twitch link
now there's always people new people
from from YouTube migrating to twitch
I can play Bishop d3 or Bishop a4 here
oh good to see you too
thanks so much George Bishop d3 actually
yeah let's play there's a d3
so I'm sure a lot of people will ask why
I'm not streaming on YouTube and it's
one of those things when you're a twitch
partner you you agreed to stream
exclusively on Twitch so the the general
strategy is stream on Twitch and then
upload later to YouTube let's play play
night 95 I have a lot of time to think
but it's a pretty simple position to
play I think I'll play 95 is it it fixes
a bishop here the bishops tied down to
the pawn can't draw heroes but the plan
is potentially f4 f5 and then fork oh
thanks so much
Benji Bob but not quite still far away
and I didn't prepare any like confetti
or fireworks that's probably a good
thing
hey it's 999 someone clip it screenshot
it and send to Ben fangled before before
the nines go away
I feel like this moment is gonna be very
short-lived
hey thanks everyone so the three people
who subbed simultaneously thank you two
guards or something on Twitch Dubai do I
celebrate what do I do
I didn't really prepare any any sort of
celebratory visual effects but the chats
the the chat will be my source of energy
thanks chats what's the play here I can
still play playa for this this will be
my celebratory pawn smile
yeah that happens quickly but that it
took it did take all the time all the
work
oh thanks so much who is that and Chad
is going too fast
near off and thank you like Samir III
really appreciate like all the all the
support from everyone all the viewers
all the followers subscribers cross
twitch and of course YouTube I'll be
doing doing a lot more in the days weeks
and months to come and years to come
let's not watch this let's take a night
and trades are nice thanks so much yeah
let's saw where where's the check thanks
Chad it's hard it's hard to juggle this
scheme and address everything like the
Judy - it's only logical Smurf or the
bishop so uh what was I gonna say so
many things to say so I was planning to
uh I was thinking I would I would hit
100k like sometime next week but in the
last in the last like 12 hours over over
a thousand people subscribed on YouTube
I made a slightly unexpected appearance
last night on the chest base India
stream let's take up on let's take up on
ac4 is uh as blacks plan I'll take up on
there's a nice idea night a for actually
not sure how nice it is
94 attacks of Bischoff it does a lot of
this takes a C file would open actually
Brooke c1 followed by Knight c5 in that
line looks very very playable
I just want to trade down and simplify
not mess this up
so last night I got a message from
basically the the main person at chess
base India International Master Sagar
Shah and he basically was explaining to
me that like one of the like a famous
Indian comedian used one of my London
like one of these London traps in a
recent competition and then he just sent
me a link to a zoom call I joined the
zoom call and then started chatting with
him and someone else so I didn't
immediately know and a few minutes into
the zoom call I realized we were alive
on the chest base India Channel in front
of like over a thousand people now I
spent some time like showing some some
more London opening traps and then and
somehow like they got they got like the
whole audience to to subscribe on
YouTube so it was nice speaking of nice
so many things are nice thanks everyone
yet again the bishops attack the Knights
pressured Black has a few choices here
black can can retreat the bishop or take
my bishop with Chuck
she wondering I can play bishop there's
a b-52 weird
kingi to as possible maybe just 83 play
a three I'd be okay if if black takes
black would get the bishop era but then
the the center would would strengthen
yeah it's hard to know who the 100,000
subscriber is oh hey Pam that's awesome
to hear I hope I'm putting out enough
new content that you don't have to watch
like the same videos over and over wait
what to do here I can fight before I
think before is is a decent way to try
and justify the night some idea of night
like c5 but also just b5 and just
pushing the pawn I probably want to at
some point play King f2 in the event of
rook e8
I'd be a mean prank to all unsubscribe I
think there's a youtuber that did that
like they have a channel of like hundred
ten thousand and they just got like
maybe 20,000 people at unsubscribe it
was crazy
and why not castle counseling takes a
lot of effort because then you have to
like move to pieces rather than just one
also because so this is very common and
less less of a joke but because we're
we're kind of approaching an endgame
Queens are off the board usually you
want your king as more of an active
player and it's okay to like have the
king in the center it's not really a
target here hey thank you
pinchy pot oh yeah I still have a lot of
things to do with with Channel points
I'm brainstorming ideas plea for the
pawns defended these pawns are actually
really nice now controlling a lot of
squares if some b5 idea
I know people have commented before that
like I'd I don't Castle as much as as
other people but always depends on the
situation
King f2 is also played to get the rook
in g6 Thank You Carrick 22 bits um I
could play b5 it still takes work to
convert this position now I play b5 I'm
not really breaking through
I play Bishop b5 that's probably met
with some King move I could be patient
though thanks so much
how do I say that name ke ke Taji 96 I
appreciate that
what's my favourite end game that's not
like common question I usually get the
question what's my favorite opening a
favorite end game enlighten mission made
is fun can be fun to execute
at this point I mean I guess I'm still
just trying to improve the pieces at
some point b5 maybe at some point like
rook C 1 and C 4 also this night the
night is looking a bit a bit grim on the
rim
thank you some sums sums let you hundred
bits do I think the Alekhine is fun Alec
kind is not an opening I I've played
much you kind of just concede space and
you move the same piece in multiple
times but it's a counterpunching opening
so it has some I have some idea to it as
a volume still low I think the volume
can move the mic a little bit closer do
I get a YouTube play button I don't know
how it works
I wonder I'm sure it's not like
immediate but I'll have to look it up
I'll probably just search it on YouTube
like how to apply
hmm
I'm trying to figure out like where my
night belongs there is there's Bishop e5
there's a bishop a6
potentially play e5 okay I have an idea
night b2 idea to play I'm realizing my
knight belongs on d3 to blockade this
pawn and the bishop will sit here this
will be also be probably a nice way to
improve thank you disco dog Oh for
subbing yes I've just I've addressed
this um a few times last stream and also
the stream but yeah the last like week
or two it has just been swamped Remy and
working breaking on a cover story for
chests life so I had to put a lot of
things aside but feel like it was a nice
nice time to return oh thank you thank
you idiot creep it's an interesting name
I'm drinking drinking rebel cold label
or the gold label slightly invisible my
verified on YouTube
actually II I don't know maybe I'm just
an impostor does YouTube have a
verification program okay so the
question is Bishop Bishop b5 herb Bishop
a6
Bishop ah can use a tog II command get
more information as tog II otah he's not
here takis missing a part of history so
there should be five there's rook c7 it
should still be okay though the bishop
can maneuver night will come in the rook
will probably be bust on c1
while John's D with a big proposition
will donate 100 K bits if I finished top
three I feel I feel like that would be
that would be interesting if I'll try
four hours I'll try if a few hours pass
and it doesn't seem like I'll make it
and that'll be life but okay so the goal
is now to finish top three which means I
should probably play a bit quicker oh
they probably take completely five I'm
just trying to simplify and open a file
okay that's enough taggi commands yeah
here's a time left in the tournament so
yeah I could be here for a while
also hello hello to the mods the ice
welcome back and liquid sword how's it
going I can consider that could be
interesting and black is putting off the
fight here thinking c4 takes well Brooke
c1 is met by c2 or work takes g2 I'll
still play c4
so take stakes and rook c1 up upon I
still like my chin my my chances
yeah yeah if you guys have channel point
recommendations feel free to to suggest
I was making a list other day but I was
also thinking of having like designated
stream streams for redeeming channel
points like a workout stream redeem
points for push-ups or a Q&A stream or I
could just do the hikaru approach yeah
redeem points for for nice the thing is
it's hot like always have to like
acknowledge if someone redeems or if
like a dozen people redeem points at the
same time like if a dozen people
recommend an opening at the same time
then it's not so effective mmm push a
challenge
I have to get in shape to start lifting
I'd be more down for like a running
challenge okay how do I win this it was
not so simple to win I mean this move is
logical
I'm playing actually a pretty pretty
decent player to be five is interesting
yeah
thanks so much hey it's talkie-talkie
you missed you missed the epic
celebration but you're still here still
in time for a lot of chess okay I have
an idea
rookie three it looks like just a
retreating move but the the main purpose
is that the bishop really wants to be
here and not the rook once the bishops
here the pawns defended ideas of rook c7
will be possible and the main plan is
Bishop e5 rook c3 rook c7 there we go
yeah tog II emotes flooding the chat
also don't mess with tog II here's a mod
let's play wait a minute so if I play
Bishop b5 takes takes rook d3 Keaney to
takes rook c7
not so simple really rocky 7 that's
probably the way to go
rookie 7 I'm okay trading one one pair
of rooks I'm not okay trading two pairs
of rooks
yeah so if I want to make a running to
actually like finish highly in this
tournament I'm gonna have to the zerk
every every game going forward yeah
let's do this
this could be interesting Bishop f6
bikini - also possible
I'll play King you two first the idea is
to prepare this and not allow raqudii to
rook to e3 I'll probably play a four
basically unpin the bishop hey its core
blah Oh core blah Charlotte's a core
blah I saw you streaming yesterday tog
II talkie can probably answer that tigey
is a master of bits I was watching core
blood stream the other nights he was
losing this is some bullet came and then
and he was winning and he started
dancing and trash-talking it was
beautiful I don't know if I'll have
energy for Scrabble
after the however many hours I play this
but we'll see if you manage to stick
around that and maybe it's possible
yeah 900k to go until the what is it the
golden or platinum I don't know how the
play buttons work can we see you again
on chess pays India yeah it's on YouTube
maybe I'll make another appearance we'll
see
this is actually an interesting approach
kind of provoking rook to e3
they've rook here then I'll keep walking
the king up nicola solving a tier 3 for
18 months thanks so much
nicola not entirely sure about that be
an interesting conspiracy
okay so it feels like I'm making
progress but I'm not sure I have a pawn
pawn majority on the Kings side Oh
three-on-two so the the way to
eventually win this game is to someday
make a pass pawn on the Kings side and
then make a queen and then meet but it's
not easy to do because the pawns are
blockaded black's threatening rook t3
play rook c3 so it takes yeah it takes a
lot of technique to to actually convert
this
people want the NAG Mundson I've been
trying to play them that mints in for a
while I'm happy to finally have gotten
this song this opening for those maybe
just joining this is kind of my secret
preparation opening I've been wanting to
play for a while
that's probably a good move
like you need to
praying praying for Richie one just
attack my pond it's a weakness Bishop g4
I'll play King f2
actually maybe I'll play King can walk
up to d3
on the walk in Nicola with a thousand
bits thanks for watching Nicole uh
sharing 25 emotes oh wait did we repeat
we repeated so can you two really didn't
didn't make any sort of progress this is
not easy to win play each 3hv it's a bit
double-edged but I like it yeah so idea
with each three is to fix the spawn on a
dark square and then eventually win it
with a bishop I have to be careful in
doing so because there's rookie one
skewer ideas and the drawback to h3 is
my pawns are fixed on light squares
there might be some like eventual Bishop
efore but for the time being like this
pawn safe always have King f2 he wrote
to you one King f2
now the goal is to somehow attack the
pond with the bishop or maybe even push
this could be a long game all right
let's play Bishop you also have this
move Bishop d6 is probably rook see
force coming
it's tricky
I'll play Bishop d6 a bit more active
I'm trying to calculate the the prospect
of taking it's close to winning takes
takes and then this
hmm it's very committal though I kind of
like it it might be a draw but yeah
let's play King III preventing Bishop e4
and now this is unstoppable like officer
collar bunch of endings usually have a
pretty trashed tendency but when you're
up to pawns then should be seven yeah
when you're up to pawns and there's a
bit more hope
I may have just miscalculated though
okay opponent miss Polly missed an
opportunity there but the plans can be
five it's still tricky this is very
tricky
let's play and this is one of the only
moves I did g-41 let's start pushing the
kingside pawns yeah black black have a
forest draw involving before I took the
pawn involving like some Bishop b4 and
c2 so if ever block play see - I had
this in this
meanwhile yeah meanwhile if Kings like
pawns are rolling just to show up let me
let me play the game first in g4
Angie for looks right bishops gonna have
to move I'm considering a five the idea
of f5 and then then g5 I could start
with each for though each word let's
start with each for a five will probably
come very soon just to show the simple
draw for black it did require a few
moves but it was on c2 king d too busy
for takes takes and I lose this pawn
annum Bach can set up a BA a pretty
simple blockade but yeah it took a few
moves of calculation took some
understanding - there's a b1 trying to
confuse me
so I think I think I 5 is just winning
I'm not sure not sure if I need to
calculate much yeah cuz g5 will come and
even if luck
so luck has one tried to blockade with
this invisibly six but the Kings always
gonna help the pawns push and the bishop
will always keep an eye on this pawn I
mean very likely I'm okay
I was gonna say I could sacrifice but
yeah now the bishop can't even access
this diagonal so this worked out or did
it kingi three bishop here I think it's
working out Bishop c1 it's a very
unusual position King here oh I thought
I could just push also push this way
there we go
man that took that took a lot of work a
nice game thanks for the game LVN 2k
yeah so it should have been a draw that
was a fun opening though I can try and
find let's see xq CBR Chelsea CVR no
can't find the video I'll have to all
have to dig and find the video but it
was a video where X you see basically
played this without Queen h5 though I
have to hurry up yeah ok let's get let's
get to top three still need to break
into the top thousand Thank You
followers followers one something for
two months
ok berserk time was working every game
no time to waste
have to catch up to the bomb in oh thank
you lv n 2k ok boo the past time no
touch at least here playing playing a
favorite variation Sri Lanka mm-hmm I've
never been to Sri Lanka that seems like
a nice country the ice Otaki
gifting us up to the ice thanks so much
talk II appreciate that
yeah in general I don't usually mind if
people play against me and and listen to
the stream I usually try and try not
like say anything too too strong for the
ponent when it matters I do have a
discord server I'm not too active on
discord personally but server is is
usually a place where where fans can
interact so in this line I'll start with
rook rook e8 very often at some point
we'll trade nights I'm kind of waiting
for this in this if white doesn't take
very likely I'll take and then play 95
and then some idea of a 5 which feels so
different than YouTube oh it's your
first day on Twitch so how many people
here like saw my most recent Youtube
upload and then clicked the link either
in the pinned comments or the video
description because I posted the video
about 45 minutes ago so a few means in
the chat
that's nice
yeah thanks everyone who I guess who
commented and liked the video thanks so
much dude one one four I appreciate that
so a three is a very typical move from
from white to prepare before but it's
actually it's more useful for me hey
it's Ryan with 300 bits thanks so much
welcome back Ryan yeah so the reason why
a three benefits me more than white is
cuz a 5 is more multi-purpose the only
purpose with a 3 was to prepare before
which is now prevented and the purpose
of a 5 not only to prevent b4 but also
the secret idea of lifting a rook and
then and eventually checkmating and
that's one of the reasons why I want the
Knights trading so that the the six rank
becomes clear hey Neil how's it going
so it's Brian but also says me hope
you're doing well
okay so yep Bishop d2 it's a little bit
passive more often white wolf being kind
of the bishop to a happier place
so everything so far is like very
typical Budapest's ideas thanks so much
I am Avalon oh I have I have the Avalon
game somewhere it used to be the mic
stand
oh I forgot okay let me let me actually
get it I've moved it Avalon it's still
in its original packaging because I have
to social distance myself from other
people but um I mean move them like a
top of this I forgot that there
sometimes like mic vibrations when I
don't have the mic on the stand
alright Knights
yeah 94 is actually a decent move
usually um but in this position I don't
know how I'll play Bishop I fates it was
one of the ideas with rookie a to very
often than Bishop just kind of chills on
that fate and now now there is pressure
against the bishop against the I mean
the pawn is basically hanging here super
excited hey Harry Krishnan is also back
thanks so much
am I ready to face Hikaru I was born
ready
I have experienced against Hikaru now so
now I'm kind of less nervous when I play
him but it's still terrifying and thank
you DNA one for one premiere yeah so I
mean his position is pretty rich with
ideas and there's this idea at some
point I want to play d6 you'll see what
the plate is up to I might even just
want to take the bishop play
positionally because I'm this Bishop
could come to life so it's it's a tricky
situation for white hmm I was not so
expected because the issue is this
bishop I could take and then work a6
combined with combine with this and this
like it's very close to meeting already
can I do a match against Gotham chess
actually I did a match against him I
stayed at his place a few months ago
oh thanks so much jog jog Riyadh I
appreciate that question is how to
execute you'll start with Queen
an idea for white is obvious I'll start
with Queen here it's a very four seam
line of course expecting this and they
were gauge 600 G 2 and then I was
thinking Queen each five rang the phone
let's go
yeah that's it's not gonna be easy to
get like so many games in because every
game can potentially last like half-hour
so that's I could just have less than 10
games this tournament
Oh Thank You malice of forethought I'm
trying to think ahead with my head there
might be some idea of of rook takes e4
like rook g1 rocky 4 Fe 4 Queenie for
rock g2 or g6 this is all forcing and
maybe b6 in the end idea Bishop there
should be 7 I honestly don't see what
light does against that cuz it's not
it's basically an internal pin I mean
there's each three but then okay I take
and it should be seven is meaningless
Queens on the play
I I don't see any other way for white to
defend this pawn other than this and
this okay so hop on it plays that yeah
so takes takes rook g2 or g6 it's all
forcing and then b6 then the question is
does white have any resources to defend
there's one resource that I see which
I'm not gonna say maybe there's a couple
at the very least I'll be up I'll be up
a pawn in the winning end game
it's good enough for me but anything
more now I'm thinking of this and then
rookie just six I'll it's just good for
this it's all forcing I guess my point
was expecting that
so it's possible my opponents watching
the stream if they pre moved a fee for
alright oh there's a cool idea I'm not
gonna go for it I was thinking rook so
this is only move rook here and then
rook each six idea of meeting like
sacking of a rook and then just meeting
on each for the problem with rook age 6
is f4 and then the rooks actually
misplaced but this this idea is very
hard to meet
sorry if I'm I'm like missing things in
the chat I'm trying to focus on the game
play some quality chess offers some some
commentary I hope people are are
interacting amongst themselves and I
thought people keeping people company
yeah so this is a one resource for white
f3 and the issue for white is I just
take and it's very pleasant I'm winning
back the exchange I'll probably just
leave white suffering I give the H pawn
moves I'll play this to prevent king h2
and then white is completely stuck yeah
maybe you know it's it's getting old
it happens yeah there's so much fun that
can be had after Bishop Bishop d6 I
think rook here it takes okay thanks for
the game gliscor X hey top thousand top
700 let's go ox on 88 slumming at Tier
one and Confused dragon with 200 of
course so I forgot who it was but
someone offered a hundred thousand bits
if I finish top three I have three three
three five five amount of time to do so
oh the Dutch forgotten I maybe I'll play
it against someone I don't know though
like I'm racing against the clock so I
have to play openings that win as
quickly as possible and the Dutch
doesn't really fit that category I mean
it's an interesting dynamic opening but
to win quickly I want to stick with like
for the past
Stafford
we'll see one in time
actually don't know what's more popular
like among players of this level in
London or or poncey for hmm or the
tracks or gambit hard to play either
against d4 so if one's thinking let's
play play d5 I'm not over the pass
I don't know what that means no hablo
German blue Alps thanks for subbing at
tier 1 sorry yeah the focus is a bit
weird on the camera we're like it'll
focus on one thing and then it will go
out of focus but we can cope dr. Lowe no
welcome back thanks for subbing for 12
months for one year
happy anniversary up one's already
perplexed
yeah yes I guess if you haven't seen the
Budapest before at first maybe it looks
like a mouse lip and then then you
realize like okay black house initiative
some people just don't care about
defending the pawn others try and defend
it with everything possibly but also
enactments and gambit that Minson might
be more likely we'll see I haven't been
white in a while interesting you three
will only move here I don't really
follow German football oh but that's how
you cheer Oh interesting
all these like kind of overlaps between
cheering from a stadium and cheering in
the twitch chat horse checkmate someday
someday up ones taking a lot of time I'm
not used to being on the defensive so
early
yeah if I don't encourage people to to
donate more than they can afford so if
that was if that was just kind of a a
joke it's completely okay don't don't
take out loans that you you should dr.
Noah Schmo thanks for subbing with prime
I'm still gonna try and win this
tournament though it'd be good good good
content
the time times even seems to move so
quickly but also so slowly it's so
unusual like this clocks moving quickly
and this clocks moving slowly it so
weird from that phenomena Queen d5 it's
a move that does defend the pawn however
it doesn't it doesn't sufficiently
defend the pawn and very often the Queen
won't be targeted at some point in the
future now usually in the opening you
should not put your queen in the like
smack center of the board
I'm an exact opposite of the streamer
begging for subs well I don't know that
that would be Carlson Carlson doesn't
even like enable subs I'm very
appreciative of when people sub but like
I don't want people to like take out
loans to to subscribe or donate also
taki
I appreciate taki let's uh let's castle
there's Mike being night before just
queen g1 was just Castle maybe there's
some decision to make how to complete
development I'm gonna continue playing
like some flexible moves over to finding
the night still kind of drawn to this
move at some point
thanks so much Holly gifting sub gifting
5 subs - soaking wet psy
wire timeframe hoon r09 filarsky Guara
SEMA and dr. no Shamu gifting a sub to
AIDS 3 5 9 and fini fini
solving for 3 months thanks fini fini
let's play I find that before night
before still quindi one ire I am one of
those okay hey nice ya thinks everyone
especially all 100,000 people who are
subscribed maybe some people subscribed
on multiple oh yeah I think stalky I
appreciate that
and thanks Brian wait what to do it's
actually tricky it's one of life's most
difficult questions I'm playing a five
for two reasons maybe three reasons
reason number one preventing future
before reason number two
giving the square for the bishop in the
event of 94 and reason number three of
course is to execute the real ift's yeah
94 is also possible so I'll play this
hey smack my bishop thanks for the 80
bits but also retreat my bishop there's
some weird idea of Bishop B AIDS or the
bishop looks lifeless but then
eventually like takes exactly
but what to do hmm because usually the
bishops on f8 okay I think I'll go ahead
and take 95 or maybe Queen e5 I don't
know let's play play 95 how happy to see
the Queen land here am I currently
playing with viewers I might be playing
with a single viewer right now I don't
know but I'm playing in the for those
unaware I'm playing the monthly
classical arena and it's a decently long
tournament which I'm gonna try and do
well in okay this is a second budapest
rook lift game in a row the first one
went well
hey it's Shane 66 loving a tier 1 thanks
so much
[Music]
I can't believe it's not bitter butter
better what do you think of 1.d4 nf6 to
bf4 c53 e3 and d5 question mark oh
that's a playable opening and you play
queen c6 I took a break for a bit but
now I'm back yeah that line it's very
playable like pockets really initiative
but if White's careful it's not what's
on van chuck
if van is that like the combination of a
vampire and a woodchuck or a van and a
chuck or a van named Chuck also this is
a good move play I mean I only have one
square for the night I think we've
entered that point in the stream where
the Mesopotamia bits are not too far
away
Oh Yvonne Chuck
Yvonne oh oh I'm so sorry - Yvonne look
what did I say a vampire with Chuck okay
this is a free free pawn I don't want to
trade Queens oh thanks so much so why
can't make me cuz whites in check man
there's so many like word plays on
Yvonne show this is a free queen Wow
unexpected butas gambit opponent was
like hoping to still turn meat like king
each one threatens made in one thought
not the best life decision
okay resignation coming in three two
what's the delay on the stream case of
one's watching one
maybe not but okay I'm attacking bishop
I'm attacking a pawn
yeah I've been getting the question a
lot I was working on this this trust
life cover story for the past like
several weeks it took most of my time
and energy but I'll be posting to
youtube a lot more they'll probably do I
want to do some like more opening
content and also just more feedback and
more more instructive chess as well Wow
100,000 103 thanks everyone for
something I appreciate it on YouTube and
on Twitch
drunk walked into a bar it hurts quite a
bit ah like a metal bar Oh opponent
reach quits
Oh da Li chose had like the clean
victory thing I think the timer but
that's kind of sad
let's be productive what to do I could
read through YouTube comments
I could make a form let's make a Google
Form Oh bones gonna yeah Pony rage quit
kudos from each ass for for having this
feature so now I could actually I could
accurately count down 2019 okay making a
Google Form
oh that's that's deep clean victory know
what what did I just do
there I'm just gonna keep clicking here
there we go okay
we chess was trolling me um I thought I
did something but okay so I want
beautiful doctor tournament so we need
teeth questions
okay I'm just making a very simple
google form you're ready
specify okay the Mariana Trench
ooh okay so I just made the form I think
I'll send this in the chat whoa it's
Rory leopard gifting subs
okay Stafford gambit I'm also it's a fur
gambit accepted Bishop d3 Bishop d3 is
not a common move I actually I saw
though the first time I encountered this
move I was playing Jenna Hadi in in
giant CrossFit chests and we went into
exactly this line it was like some it
was chests with giant pieces and we had
to do like exercise after capturing
every piece and we thought we had
something very similar to this we're
just a classic meat let's take off
things the Queen f3 i-it's forcemeat
Thank You Rory Leopard gifting Suggs -
OH mass pure Scott ancient Daniel power
NL this is a double check oh that's
unfortunate I hope you can look forward
to the future or maybe the past it's
another it's another double check thanks
so much
I was double double check thanks talking
how much for a beer the Nutri asks for
you it's so hard to like internalize
these these clever jokes or statements
but think okay thank you
who do I have to think Thank You Raoul a
bird gifting subs to people who are I
think I already said I'll Mouse P or
Scott ancient Daniel power and I'll I
eat play-doh win some lose more oh
that's kind of sad
but then you learn more - Gary Gary
something for two months thanks Gary and
gifting a sub to homeless Pluto homeless
Pluto alright let's go let's play Oh
goodbye talky
[Music]
thanks for being here
thanks for all the support Lucy five
wants to play a dragon it happens Thank
You slim g7 sudden we have a Marathi
bind these noises tough
thanks so much people I appreciate it I
have to be careful here I'm just hoping
we can transpose him to some some kind
of mainline a okay mainline time so this
is this is the the basic setup of a
Marathi bind thank you Hari Krishna
thank you to yell as llama something a
tier-one
appreciate that let's play a six is not
a typical move but I don't know if it's
a move I can punish
I'll go for this development Oh confused
dragon and confuse dragon is basically
what my point is playing very confused
to play a six
I mean piece is better than war right
wait what to do
castle and the chat the child is too
good today with the puns are too bad I
don't know you know how to subscribe
these these messages so I'm looking for
ways to punish my opponent I think it's
just a matter of playing some solid
moves and letting black suffer with a
space deficit
oh yeah the Google forum commands and so
there's a forum so you can basically
just submit openings that you want to
see more instructional content on blocks
really asking for trouble here is it
sometimes sometimes it's not so peaceful
even though it's full of pieces I'll
play Queen d2 very soon this move even
though there's a pawn on e6 this move
should be playable alignment wait really
let me check back oh it shouldn't be
unless it is in which case I I apologise
for
wait okay a few things to address here
first of all can I win a pawn can take
on c6 and then g6 looks nice oh it works
huh so some people can access it others
can't when I click on it it looks like
it looks like this maybe if you're on
mobile
they might depend what device you're on
not sure I should rename the form of 79
requests
whoa whoa 80 over 80 people have
submitted the form I wonder if it's
maybe high traffic is preventing some
people that's incredible
all right so I mean the position is very
good it's just a question how to how to
trap the Queen and before oh yeah you
might have to be on desktop I don't know
people can discuss hmm I actually don't
know what to do here ha ha ha ha ha I
get it
thank you lucky lucky picks something
with Prime oh it doesn't stop okay so
the whole idea of Queen g3 was to create
this battery
[Music]
he lost his case mmm ha ha feeling
that's probably happened before exactly
that
okay the queen is almost trapped and by
almost I mean yeah just almost I have
this move so I'm hitting the roof I'm
trying to like prevent the Queen from
escaping along the fifth-ranked there
are some lines to address if we're like
this is a move Locke wants to play that
it walks into this so rook c8
it's very close if I play b4 b4 Queen a
3 B 5 Queen a 3 B 5 that's so unusual
hmm
like all these moves look nice but they
don't quite win anything concretely so
I'm looking for a way just to prepare
like even the smooth let's do this may
be the wrong decision but we'll see I am
I am up upon the idea is to play nine a
four and and target a square even more
still want to consider this Bishop let's
go 494 yeah unleash this Bishop oh the
only ask for Oh No I messed up I messed
up the form damn people are delete the
command to leave the command people you
are just submitting their ratings that's
so bad some people are using the rating
form to tell openings like bond cloud
has been suggested the most well this
move the song was rookie to move
play rook t1 oh thank you
new subs so many things to do and
address I don't want to lose this game
may the force coming to this is actually
a good move hmm I'm gonna play Queen III
so preventing that a4 should still be
decent yeah this is what happens when I
try and like make a form and play chess
at the same time I love your YouTube
videos Eric thank you oh thank you I
appreciate that
okay it should be fixed now also bid
would be six I think just wins a better
win I'm sorry oh that was a good move oh
snap okay it's not so bad
I forgot Bishop c4 twins back the Queen
thankfully it's just a big trade and
I'll have a nice e3 in the end defending
this in this so everything should still
be okay
I'm under pressure though I think things
are defended Bishop f1 coming if we
train like this bishops just out of play
I'm always defending a2 as well
okay I think the form should be updated
yeah the form should be updated I really
messed that up yeah let's play Bishop
Bishop our phone looks nice neither of
us have increments oh thanks for subbing
and thanks for the bits confused dragon
Oh weird why your time frame says the
forum works properly okay that's nice
it's gonna be a mess going through the
responses given that a chain tied
changed it after like 200 submissions
were or submitted I think G 3 is a move
it's a legal move and nice thing the the
bishop dominates a knight so nice gonna
have to retreat very likely the king can
come in or the night will come here but
yeah this is this is what I wanted it's
another endgame I've had a lot of games
this tournament where like I'll win upon
this case my opponent doesn't fight
ended very abruptly 125 let's go whoa so
yeah all the top players are busier King
not easy not easy to catch up cuz I'm
chasing I'm basically chasing a finish
line that's continually going further
away from me
100,000 subs and 1000 views so what does
that equate to so for every so one out
of every hundred subs is watching the
stream
hopefully it specifically for so the
previous game was some sort of modern it
was actually a Sicilian like Dragon
Marathi mind I'll play this line a
scandi time whoa oh that's good
nice thank you Hari Krishna forms pret
so this is actually a buck house opening
I played this black let's keep
developing doc wants to play b5 I just
want to focus in the center like usually
when the opponent disobeys opening
principles you should follow opening
principles accelerate development
control the center attack things if not
six all play Bishop g5 it's already very
pleasant position or Leopard gifting a
sub to AJ the chess kid whoa it's it's
Last Samurai
shout out to JJ thanks for the ride JTA
we should have a JJ command right yeah
check out JJ the last seven samurai on
Twitch an urban school clamp
thanks for something if you're just
joining I'm playing chess I'm playing
the monthly classical arena
I joined slightly late but I'm trying to
win it
I started in I started at the bottom and
now I'm here trying to break into the
top hundred very pleasant opening so far
trying to understand some of these
comments in the chat
probably better understanding or trying
to understand this position let's play
Bishop d3 a position like this there's
usually like a lot of lot of options I
don't want to waste time whoa breakfast
Oh breakfast tea time
at first I heard breakfast tea time well
it is nice when the opponent gives a
pawn a free pawn in the opening I'll try
and keep making it look slightly simple
like I want to I want to meet here
there's ninety four there's Queen h4
there's a the pawn thrust I think I'll
go for this idea to play ninety four
next actually there there's a few ideas
here there's Knight d4 Knights are gonna
come alive thanks so much
EU is one two three something to cheer
want o new sub yeah let's start with
Knights there there's a lot of nice
possibilities here
I could play tonight efore Bishop e7 I
think I'll start with this there's a
line so the idea is still a knight c6
remove the Queen win the night if Bishop
d7 I still play knight c6
and after takes takes this Knight is
removed from defending it's its
companion and I'll probably win the
night and then like the most likely
mating move is Queen d7 thank you - take
care - or tidge kids gare de solving a
Tier one for two months play quickly I'm
trying to play quickly I can't really
control how much how quickly my opponent
plays hey it's Brennan what's up Graydon
Charlotte Oh Brandon thanks for joining
Oh Brandon laughs win yeah I've had this
hundred Kangol I guess for for a decent
amount of time it's not been like a
primary goal and just been focusing on
I'm trying to make interesting content
and instructive content now I guess I
have to have to find some some other
arbitrary goal maybe one one one one one
or maybe 200k I don't know I am so I'm
gonna make an effort to do more like
collaborations - it seems like it's
becoming more of a thing like in like
among chess rumors and youtubers I think
it's great for the overall community so
like possible matches or like just kind
of hand and brain or q and A's I've been
been in talks with some people
my schedule is hopefully gonna be more
more open this month but I had my first
kind of one of those the collaboration
or guest appearance for for chess base
India about about 15 hours ago and it
was fun how I heard about though chess I
think I have I have a long list of like
stream ideas and that should be that
should be on my list
happy six-month anniversary area stream
oh that's nice thank you so much patch
up the check
21:04 player chest too
yeah that's that's become a big thing
but I'm gonna make an effort also also
just get more feedback and try and use
like Google formulas
that's a skewer black can try and
counter my skewer with discovery but I
counter counter it with just taking
okay let's take her first in the 95 or
rook t5 hollyrock d5 thank you
mckagan I had a match with Ben uh not
too long ago
just making sure there's Queen I for
Bishop a4 trying to construct some sort
of meet eventually maybe involving our
thinking involving this pawn pushing I
am trying to win the tournament it's
hard like this person is really running
away from the pack less than three hours
left Hari Krishna and I don't know what
that means but thanks for the glory bits
yeah mapa for work okay let's just push
the pawn oh I forgot about that
actually I saw that but I guess just
have to deal with it I really enjoyed
learning from you yeah that's definitely
going to be a bigger priority and
probably doing more like exclusive
YouTube content or even doing like kind
of designated lecture streams where like
I don't have TTS I don't have alerts and
then spend like like a short amount of
time like 15 20 minutes showing an
opening on stream and then they'll be
specifically for YouTube I play this
move
everything's defended pieces are talking
to each other as Queen the screen is
actually short on squares I mean the
goal is just to eventually meet thinking
back rank mean is more likely
well thanks everyone thank you JK Furman
and flads for the pits
let's take yeah let's take a bishop and
then rookie for just simplifying it's an
interesting dynamic like positions
positions like this where it's
completely winning but you still want to
win and the most efficiently possible
Queen d5 was tricky covering the square
okay I don't know some people value the
thumbnails so much
oh the badge the channel badge okay I
may have been right earlier that g7 will
be the mating square so yeah when I
first started you to like I paid no
attention to thumbnails it was just
basically using YouTube's like automatic
like I think it captures the middle
frame of the video
remember the early days on youtube like
thumbnails weren't really a thing okay
ooh I didn't get to meet but okay that
was nice
staying clean I think the first game was
definitely the the most difficult where
my opponent had a draw in this end game
but other games have been nice and
aggressive so I'm trying to do the math
I started the tournament when they were
like maybe just under five hours left so
no lady for let's play another one yeah
that's one reason why I made the the
opening request for him is to get a
sense of kind of what openings people
want to see g-force a move I think I'll
stick with my main repertoire c5 c3 see
you back oh good to see you geez Bates
welcome back solving for 14 months
thanks so much
Bishop d3 so Bishop e7 is not like a
main main line I think with this move
order like the idea of Bishop you sevens
to play Knight h5 so nutty 5 just
prevents 9 h5 now even g4 can deal move
which is g4
highly aggressive London but like with
h6 it's very much provoking me to to
attack I'll take with a pawn and
something like h4 g5 9 of three even
Queen B 1 is interesting it's an
interesting position Queen B 1 there's a
5 but that should be good for me I'm
just curious like this this night is
almost trapped on each 7 weirdly enough
if Knight g5 each workshops a night g6
lenses upon so f v a5 still playable I
could take I could take play g5 maybe
taking player up to you one
also take here let's take here so I'm
gonna have control over a five I think
it's a very risky way of playing how g5
unexpected
pretty quickly to be visible five
okay now each four it looks very
promising even f4 there's also Bishop h7
funny move oh there's so many ideas
I think I'll start with h4 bones playing
very quickly putting some decent moves
but I don't think I'm too afraid just
trying to get all my pieces into play
it's coming it's coming like with these
this pawn something like g5 is it's
gonna be hard to stop I think
opponent from France yeah g5 let's go
so I've neglected castling neglected
this rook but I mean these things are
seemingly working together quite well a
lot of g5 emotes in the chats I mean
this is a whole plan like starting when
black played each six to make some day
get this movement and then open the file
really not easy for a lot to deal with
I think this bishop saw the play let's
take this now this is too much fun so
this might call for like a quiet move of
some sort what
some kind of
I'm looking for like the immediate kill
here I was thinking Bishop e2
threatening Queen Queen g6 that looks
good enough also threatening the night
but once the Queen comes in so the
calculation is Knight g3 queen g6 Keeney
7 Queen g7 and then I just end up
queening anything better I also have
there should be five in these lines and
nine f7 included
but probably just each sudden here
all right life is good the crash through
didn't need to castle this game the
threats of course the fighters queening
but also that 7 and then queening I
could take 96 anything better
let's go for this ok
working my way up away from keyboard I
only learned that like Akron Tim
recently they haven't stopped if you
don't want them to stop okay let's play
I'm not gonna play Budapest opponents to
high-rated but I'm gonna play my main
rapper tour what is this I'll still play
my main rapper tour qgd exchange
variation with Bishop d6 it's off online
and then castling each six
he's London your favorite opening and
what is your second favorite London yeah
at least
okay so I have different repertories
based on Blitz versus over the board or
online blitz versus over the word but
yeah like over the board chests probably
London and time on of Sicilian online
blitz chess who the past gambit and
Stafford Gambon's play a five idea
eventually playing night before Queen d2
is not the most typical move opponent
wants to do something in the center go
for this
it's interesting approach
so this move might be coming actually
except is it actually coming takes I
don't know if I understand that
Oh Houdini oh I still don't know if I
understand that yeah this move is is
actually knowing chief I know so I'm
calculating the line after 90 74 takes
takes Bishop H - it doesn't seem right
they all just played there's a d7 here
what to do I hope you're learning
something hope you're being entertained
but what to do is ultimate question
I said vision b7 after wipe yeah let's
play Knight c7 first idea oh okay
Oh like Houdini oh now I understand
brilliance so White House Center and
space I have Bishop g5 and this pawn
this one is actually a bit of a target
this move
not sure how white defends upon okay no
I can oh if I take those bishop well
it's so tricky it doesn't work what's
very very tricky because I have this
move as well
whoa thanks people I appreciate it
this is a very tricky position when it's
raining hmm some people play me and
watch me simultaneously like I really
want to get away with taking on d4 I'm
just not sure if it works I'm a little
bit hesitant to calculate out loud as
well
hmm
there's some Queen b6 idea
I looked it was a good move 94 coming
energy five people some people in the
chat can answer that there's a lot of
experience which users watching
I assume maybe Queen b6 it's a little
problem in these lines is f7 hangs I
don't know how big of an issue that is
she wondering if I can play King h8 here
I think I will I'm leaving f7 hanging
but though the whole idea is to not
allow this with check and to target the
spawn this could end up transposing into
some of other lines it's interesting
another move I was scared about is this
move but then I think I can take ya
Bishop before it's probably a good move
okay now there's no more nutty for
I am kind of getting squeezed not a
pleasant feeling
so Queen b6
let's try Queen b6 I'm not super
optimistic about this but at least it's
it's still complicated there's some
potential in the position this pawn is
actually no longer defended oh thanks so
much love live welcome back gifting us
up to all the ELISA de eliza de 666 and
also people subbed earlier dungeon
master oh and PS pissed Ridge PS pest
rich keen each one good move so now I no
longer have this Bishop Bishop III it
just feels like I'm getting outplayed I
was this sad move it's so sad but it
does keep me alive kind of i unleashed
this bishop
but I'm basically going like full
defense idea probably Bishop here and
the knight would love to be here
interesting
now our thing other moves on queenie 7
like the the black pieces are so badly
placed here but I'm not down any
material so that's it's a start
and everything's defended it just seems
like I'm about to get body-slammed
pancake Doda pancakes toda thanks for
the kind words yeah white has a lot of
attractive options here but the number
one goal is to survive to not plunder
anything I think a very typical issue
for a lot of lower level players is that
when they get difficult positions like
this it's easy to blunder because
there's so many threats from the
opponent so it's very important when
needing the position is difficult to
still be able to cut your losses sports
not recently all the sports are canceled
right
I used to follow tennis a bit more she
used to follow bowling a lot and then
Bishop a5 is surprisingly annoying you
need some kind of b6 it's so sad but ok
see 6 was always offended I'm preventing
like c5 I'm unleashing the Queen as well
and there's some case where the bishop
just develops here find some happy
diagonal ok it's kind of wild since like
Mila threat formula 1 I have not I've
watched upon race pond races can be very
dramatic kind of I remember that was
German I don't remember the exact words
so if Queen takes c6 I I secure
oh the square is the square is gonna be
painful once the night lands there but I
can't really stop it unless unless I can
hmm
you some kind of rookie 7 it's so so
difficult to play this position okay I
don't like to complain but this position
is very worthy of complaining I don't
like this move I'm trying to cover
things okay died blunder that's probably
just really bad for me
oh wow that's is that meaning for gauge
3 it's really bad
I'm hoping I have one ounce of hope
though we need to 7 coming yeah there's
a very tiny amount of Hope here not
really please
I've only played this really well I got7
[Music]
in this move
those could very well be my first loss
in the tournaments
I was hoping for a real tough one
because Bishop fo so I don't think I'm
getting me the year but I am getting
body-slammed
it's still equal material but there's so
many ways like human pawns which is kind
of unfortunate but maybe not okay Knight
b6 I have rook b8 encounter play let's
go
oh that doesn't work at all
hmm bounce of hope I'm trying it's very
sad
yeah that's probably the nail in the
coffin once I have this idea
I'm not giving me any breathing room
always have to hope he never resigned
when you have a feeling kind of Bishop
how play this move oh no my bishop my
mission I've used a whole Bishop its
hing well I also has various checks
oh no my bishop
I keep wondering my bishop it's so
undefended
it's so undefended okay oh this isn't
quite g5 but people can still use their
g5 emotes because this is sparta right
this is Fargo I have to I have to create
some attack at the pawn store using
everything I have left
oh I miss my chance to say oh no my
pawns
that's a good move ah it's probably time
to resign unless it's not mmm have to
try this oh no my bishop can it be
something preventing life from promoting
kind of
h3 is a simple move to stop all the
threats opponent doesn't play it h3
still is still a very simple move
stopping all the threats yeah this is
pretty gruesome GG oh that was sad h3 is
actually forced mate for me for those
unaware Queen h3 when you shoot we need
to warn me okay that was my first loss
oh I stream yesterday yesterday was my
Quran comeback and now I'm here and now
I'm I mean 50th place some catching up
to do to under two and a half hours left
think you loved that didn't swamped with
work recently but making a comeback to
twitch and to YouTube second places
pause interesting
is there a difference for creator and I
sub with Prime or about your son
no it's the same it's the same amount so
the revenue split fifty-fifty but Prime
subs are I basically get I think around
250 a month let's play I'll play you for
this game the the difference at least
for the users between Prime and tier one
is problem you have to like manually
some every month and you can you can
manually sub to one streamer a lago
legends continuing the sub gifts you got
from nice yes so 100 bits is one US
dollar i know there's a lot of people
news at which that like it takes time to
learn all this like terminology we have
a scotch scotch gambit orion soon to be
scotch gambit maybe i should see for
what do i play here please see three
could potentially have a molar attack
yeah so this is an opening I played back
in childhood I played this a few times
recently on stream it's a gambit and
this was kind of the mean starting
position 94 castling and it's very
possible black will be well prepared I
wasn't able to play the enactments in
here Nachman sin requires a knight f6
instead of Bishop c5 I'm glad my
opponents thinking here because like
we're and we're entering a very
theoretical life and that needs to be
prepared for at least five to ten more
moves to not get into trouble at least
usually I did have an open yeah I had
one of those games it was a couple weeks
ago right I had this exact position
against someone who's using engine
assistance but they played Knight 85 I
think it was a weird very weird game so
here we're following the main line
that's very possible my opponent has
studied this
yeah I know boozer king does lose me the
increment but I'm trying to be
competitive I still have time to think
and with this opening yeah so so h6 is
the best move
if castling there was there's no h7 this
is very very theoretical f6 doesn't mean
so I'll be down the pond objectively
lack is doing doing quite well here
however it's still playable
unfortunately like I'm going to need
some help from my opponent so to be able
to to get some advantage those are the
time being at least so far my pawns
playing like a GM played all the theory
great to see you back Erik sloppy by
going I'll come back something for four
months I'll play rook could be three to
the pawn so i actually so when i I
learned this opening in childhood I
played this from the white side and from
the back side so this brings back a lot
of nostalgia I remember like at least
most people though they learn the
opening through f6 f6 is usually like
the end of most people's preparation I'm
actually still prepared here this is
still I'm still following a game that I
played back when I was about 1500 I mean
I was it's probably around 1800
so the whole idea of rookie 3b3 I want
to pressure this pawn and induce some
weakness
there might be a few other ideas too for
whites but there's there's a very
specific aligned which could occur which
um I don't want to reveal that yes
Annelle Vox threatening d5 if I would
have attacked the bishop and the pawn so
h3 is a simple simple response not to
get into trouble an interesting thing
here is like this King King has a
decision to me because it's preventing
the rooks from being connected and it's
not so simple to actually figure out
what to do here there are some
interesting words Thank You Hari Krishna
appreciate the bits
so I'm not doing not doing viewer
challenges right now I am playing the
the monthly classical arena
maybe I'll copy the link address and
let's make the term in command turn the
commands oh okay my opponent is falling
for edit so yeah I actually had a game
when I was younger in this exact
position and there's a six just wins on
the spot and like there there's no fight
for lockers this is just over as we
played through we played through all my
preparation it's yeah for those that
maybe don't fully fully understand this
tactic I'm simply attacking b7 the b7
pawn is pinned to the king so b6 is
illegal and black can't take the bishop
because I know it's just meaning to take
say six takes a6 Queen b7 and I just
made and there's no good way to defend
the pawn I remember when I was younger
like that when I had this in a
tournament game I I didn't know I had
not seen it before I I managed to figure
this out like over the board this was 43
digit basics idea I think typically what
black should do is King f8 like the
safest square for the King and then
eventually trying to expand ok plays
Knight 95 so I'll just work b7 maybe
there's still some fight so much sort by
taking
and then I could leave the pin I could
push maybe I'll push thanks for that
love and the truth salami so much yeah I
was gonna do a 40,000 followers
celebration for twitch as well but it
happened at the same time so yeah 100k
is it's a bit more a bit more prominent
in check yeah checking is actually quite
nice careful ah I remember that quote if
I play Queenie six King here and then
take the Queen there's rookie 7 and then
lying where I take I save the bishop and
then after King b6 rook b8 the bishop
gets trapped
so I do actually really have to be
careful but okay I'll go ahead and take
the Queen where do I check here yeah
this is actually was a funny thought
process I was so wrapped up in this line
I realized it didn't work and I just was
about to revert to this line without
considering this other candidate move
but this is much more effective because
here I'll have Queen d7 and then I hold
on to the pond
probably expecting they'd see southern
but yeah okay now I can take probably go
after this pawn actually there's a nice
fat here
rookie six to not only attack the pond
that threaten Queen takes d5 because of
the pin don't I lose the bishop yeah
well I was gonna win the cream for the
bishop anyway I'll play before at this
point I'm just going for meats phantasm
is b5 and then oh thanks so much
I like your chords subbing for four
months and passed pawn quadruple nine
welcome back that's going well trying to
to make a showing in this this
tournament all the point wants to play
rook h6 interesting let's go after the
pawn turning this oh wow I got I got
swindled oops that was not called for
am I still better
oh and Microsoft go away wait this is
not so simple anymore
this is really not simple it should
still be good I think about how Oh
deep breath I could win the night lose a
pawn win this pawn I think I want to
play a four it's gonna be really bad if
I lose this Oh actually I just realized
a nice nice little trick I'm happy with
a four I should still be winning because
the night saw the play the Queen will
have fun with the the pawns
I think this pawn is more valuable than
the Knights I didn't want to to make the
journey and put my queen on a passive
square
not easy to stop this idea as well
because the night is pretty limited like
these squares are the potential squares
to offend upon but they're all covered
by the Queen also 85 some idea
yeah that's probably the best move even
though the light looks ridiculous
they're blocking me be Phi with Knights
95
wondering if I can play this move and
just eventually put blackens legs long
let's do it
mmm I was really not necessary not for I
should have just played a 500-page six
could mean that with Queen d8 there so
many regrets
yeah it's moans like this where you
really have to be like mentally stable
and stay focused
Firenze and jostle I've heard that
saying before what does that mean g4
this is slightly terrifying oh nice
you rock oh thanks so much did you
appreciate that whoa it's confused
dragon great YouTube videos you upload
oh thanks so much thanks everyone for
yeah all the new people and thanks so
much for the bit Cheers
I I really really have to to focus here
though and probably be five
this isn't really a threat though like
kingi 3 even a 4
I'll play f4 looks like a random I'm
just waiting to see what box Agra saw
Eric thanks for that chest for brig us
yeah I was on the I was referring to the
chess basic India stream made a a
slightly unexpected appearance after my
stream last night
I'm gonna try and stay focus while also
addressing the chat I guess but yeah
though the rooks are tied down the night
really doesn't have any great squares
these pawns are still kind of doing
something I do have okay so I have like
the one extra pawn this pawn is always
hanging
this could be a long game it was on
YouTube I consider that weight on your
plate a sermon don't think I knew that
oh like the Smith Morra I think I didn't
know that
hmm okay I have actually a simple idea
of just using my king and trapping the
knight as pawns defended by my queen
queen is actually a good defensive
defensive piece here
yeah it's interesting like black is very
short on moose there's a lot of moves
like the night really doesn't have great
squares this rook is tied down or tied
down to each other the king really
curious what blocks and I do and my
planet is just like king b-24 probably
HemoCue c3 King c2
how does it work if they can give you a
sub even yeah you can gift any like
twitch user a sub so there's been people
who troll in lightful gifts gift like
ninja sub to my channel or RT foo so you
don't have to be watching a twitch in to
be gifted to the sub
as far as I know yeah the Nigel short
king walk but it'll be a long walk not a
short walk yeah stayin alive I have all
that all these ambitions to travel was
supposed to go to Vietnam in March I
kind of didn't happen looking forward to
the times to to travel again
oh that's a move
oh that's probably a good move too but
the problem with this move is that the
Knights like there's no thing defending
the pawn what do you do let me focus
question is do I move my king in her
device use my queen
like Queen d1 is actually the main
consideration
oh that's a dangerous move feels very
dangerous for some reason but I don't
see anything concretely wrong with this
these night check squares don't do
anything and the rooks are always still
like both tied down because there's a
constant through either promotion so
they can't really leave the eighth ring
I'm just trying to like to hug the night
85 oh if I was it rhymes probably a
really good idea
okay now it's probably the time for
Queen d1 not all I wanted to do but if I
was a great move I have to speed things
off too
time time is running low have to focus
no increment either thankfully the
lights trapped that's a good sign is
this idea to Quincy one to win the pond
to check the king it's actually like
that would be interesting to check the
king when the pond offend the pond and
then hit a five as well and when I for a
lot of geometry in this position I think
I'm so more inclined to take the knight
though because if I go for this and
ninety four happens yeah I went to an
elephant sanctuary in Thailand it was
pretty neat
I'm in big trouble here I'm like
objectively much worse but it's still
hopeful sometimes rooks can be hard to
heart and hard to coordinate whoa its
vampire chicken what's up fam fire
chicken reading with a party of 16
thanks so much I feel like you've been
mentioned probably a few times this
stream wait am I just losing I might
just be losing unless it could be a draw
I have to take check
hmm
a lot of checking ideas
okay
the this rook battery is really
unfortunate
okay it's a guaranteed draw this
question is if I can get more
I'm probably have to settle for a jaw
which is really sad given the opening
preparation
don't make things interesting yeah if I
take I just had me then
and I'm like sliding
curious if black will try and and do
anything weird though there's really not
too much to do
mmm okay this is this would be the
moment where I can consider something
Queen there's no time
okay
again a moment like this
no no time if I had more time I'd try
and like calculate yeah that's I would I
was gonna try and calculate Queen c2 but
I think even like rookie two takes takes
takes King here I might even just be
losing for me rough game
so I got ya
oh they're still hope wait well the P
like some some of the top players are
struggling all right let's play oh let's
play on that Vinson just for the vampire
chicken but we need we need enough six
to happen Bishop before a similar
opening I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
think you confused dragon less than two
hours left
I'm trying to play aggressively d5 what
is d5 let's kick it
there's a nice line here queen h5 takes
and then takes
okay that worked out quite nicely yeah a
lot of these like Scotch gambit type
positions are very tricky for black
oh it's squishy that's a surprisingly
sophisticated question thanks so much
that's a very sophisticated question for
squishy Hercules usually spanning the
Mesopotamia bits wait what was the
question when someone plays an opening
you've never seen before
oh yeah oh like I'll always be aware of
the plunge threats always have to think
from their perspective especially if you
are there like gambling or playing ultra
aggressively you have to be tactically
aware a big mistake a lot of people make
is that they only think about what they
want to do and even though in the
opening you have to be aware of your
opponent's ideas which is probably one
of the downfalls of my opponents in this
game also my downfall in the previous
game at least in the middle game okay so
I'm hitting the Queen Queen side down to
the knight rook team one who's likely
after Queen d7
[Music]
I mean these are the only two moves for
the Queen I do a video of getting the
silver button I have to figure out how
that works actually wondering if YouTube
do they send me like a congratulation
whoa
oh it's Zen mode I haven't done Zen not
in a while not right now yeah I'll try
and wrap this up
there's no congratulatory message from
YouTube at least yet one wants to meet
me is that the standard I think I have
to submit a form right I'm not sure how
it works some people probably know
better than me
Bishop f7 was possible earlier Oh like
here yeah I considered it I thought like
g5 was a bit more venomous but maybe
Bishop a7 was objectively Mother
let's take a thing yeah the Knights
pinned and attacked three times also
this moon was coming
ninety six everything everything is
targeted cool
yeah there's no rush I was singing about
like having a shelf behind me rather
than just having the green-screen like a
car was styled by just put I put the
whatever maybe some trophies some tea
some day okay so this is um this is
looking quite pleasant
but the question is will bloc resign get
me the flag ragequit okay meet alright
top 50 let's go
34 points I didn't say that I didn't say
that I was just impressed with a an
unexpected sophisticated question yes I
can I can show a few buzzer okay play a
Stafford gambit against someone higher
rather than me Wilde is irking here's
our here's one I've really enjoyed this
jasmine pearls it's like let me see
there's no guarantee we'll get the stuff
for you Oh Stafford gamma time let's go
also classic Irish oh it's it's kind of
invisible though people get the point
Wow opponent declines again it okay so I
mean this is already like slightly
preferable for uh for black I'll take
mean it's approximately equal but I have
a slightly slightly nicer pawn structure
easy development this is probably like
all I can ask for and a game I've like
deserts against a higher II player oh
you although GM this is probably a title
player who hasn't like made their title
able to ask a regular chess question
feels bad I'm sorry if you feel bad but
I answered your questions I hope you
feel happy oh nice I think I can get
away with I'm calculating the Greek
gifts mm-hmm there's also Queenie's
that's like wienie seven let's keep a
positional game expecting Queenie - I'll
trade I'll play d6 now I'll try - I'll
play my opponent
hmm okay let's castle and Bishop e2 I'm
happy to see because Queens stay on the
board so there's more more attacking
potential just have to play quickly so I
got the tea people can see that I mean
it's a place called Todd in Holland
there's a streamer I watch on Twitch not
a chest streamer
his name is Devin Nash and he evo choose
for this tea and it's pretty good it's
like high quality loose leaf tea ideas
of completing development
but right now I'm drinking drinking
rebel some gold label wholefoods potion
fini fini with clickbait advice oh and
Neal played this opponent I'll try and
get revenge just for Neal I play this as
Bishop a six random move that's probably
not too hurtful though so Bishop h6
Bishop f3 g f3 and then Queen h4
threatening f2 that was a good move
though ooh
then g4 happens oh I made this I was
gonna I was gonna like prepare something
[Music]
the thing is yeah I might do something
like that um I I was expecting to hit
100k and like in a few days from now but
if we check and check the numbers
in the last 12 hours over a thousand
people have subscribed something really
happened okay I can't show it yeah there
is like an unexpected event yesterday I
was featured in this chest bass India
video and then the live stream and then
so many people so many new new people
subscribed so I'll have to take some
time take a few days to make something
but thanks everyone I appreciate all the
even like the new people who are joining
joining from YouTube on twitch or vice
versa
okay so this is a positional fight each
six was nice to include to prevent this
as an IG five move
I want to redevelop the night yeah there
there was a Miss Ireland us match which
I recorded locally I'll probably be
posting on on YouTube in the very near
future
I know Livi watch me when I had a
hundred viewers that was that was only
like um mine I started streaming about
two and half years ago and then YouTube
was kind of a slow it takes a lot of
time to you're on YouTube I think you ll
Quist actually I made my YouTube channel
and I think 2015 94 can be coming okay
let's take and then Queen uh 697 looks
nice
actually I had the ambition of like
starting a chess channel years before I
I actually started she'll start at 97
I'm okay if we we end up trading
yeah maybe after this tournament if I
have the time and energy I'll go back
and like show some of the earliest
videos on my stream are my on my youtube
channel kind of talk about the evolution
I'm realizing like I could only have
like three or four more games as
tournament so my my hopes of finishing
even top ten not gonna be easy the chess
boats if only it was that simple let's
point 95 I'm playing a good enough
player where like simple simple cheap
tricks won't necessarily work but I mean
complicated cheap tricks
Bishop d7 might be the way to go
even bishop Oh what to do pre
green-screen only started using the
green screen
less than a year ago I moved in to like
the Chesbrough apartment and then but
when when is summer time for Vietnam
because the seasons are different in
Asia right yeah I would go to Vietnam
just for the the soup or maybe maybe I'm
just confused
completely lost track of what I was
saying what was I saying I can all I can
think about is like far no so the
streaming software I use is called
stream labs OBS and it's it's completely
free to download
it's basically what you need to to
stream on Twitch yay yeah but okay wait
let's focus this should be fine I don't
want to get too long time oh that's
soggy tigey's back what's up time but
yeah stream absorb yes is uh the main
software I use and it has it has all the
built-in like streaming filters and
alerts so all the text to speech and bit
alerts are are like manipulated through
stream out so via your stream labs over
yes
there's also OBS where if you use OBS
and you need to also use stream ax to to
make make things a bit more customized
oh yeah I was gonna say when I moved
into this apartment the green screen was
just sitting in the closet I didn't
realize until like a few months after I
moved that a green screen existed and it
took some time to like figure out the
exact filter and the lighting
I always trained trying to make like
small improvements hey tog II was that
tog II know that was confused dragon tog
II tog II wouldn't necessarily say that
but we all know ya tog is there should
be an MVP that addition to VIP bench
so positionally like it's it's nice for
me because these pawns are especially
this a pawn just a long-term weakness
actually the only way for white to
defend it it's rotating one otherwise
like I mean we might see takes Roque one
I lose a five Thank You Jean Jean pannu
solving with crime for six months
thanks so much I've helped a lot of a
lot of friends like kickstart their
streams if you're on Windows and the
stream labs OBS is like by far the most
recommended and gets it's a bit more
user friendly than wait free night oh no
not free nights if I take there's Bishop
each seven meanwhile whining this it's a
confusing move let's be solid I'm
waiting weakening c6 but I'm not too
afraid because all the pawns are in dark
squares which really favors this Bishop
now this and this are long-term
weaknesses a5 now forever defended late
c6 v6 doesn't do anything now I'm
threatening just to take the pond thank
you a boy Boise poker for something it's
your one appreciate that
oh and thank you I'm bowling for several
several dozen bits Bishop a5 is probably
a good move I would like to get away
with this it might work it might not
trying to calculate thanks everyone for
something I do appreciate it I'm trying
to stay focused here
I feel a lot of pressure other ideas
were he seven the problem is 96 the 96
doesn't work in those lines actually a
might mmm Bishop Bishop d7 takes takes
takes takes a the end really not easy to
judge let's start with rookie salmon
this might lead to some like repeating
but that's okay oh thank you boy secret
poker nice message that's nice to hear
and Thank You El Capitan PDX solving for
19 months and and kid doreen o and
Katerina thanks so much
it's gonna yeah it's gonna take work to
win this game
we're not even just not to flag cat with
cat with a cat slumming of Prime a lot
of new names good to see like so many
new people it's clear my it my opponents
like taking this game seriously I'm
trying to play accurately 96 was yeah
quite annoying I would have to move rook
d7 I didn't realize this when I played
rookie 7 but if you were not repeating
well thanks dude thanks for the bits
yeah I'll be I'm gonna try and stream
bit more yeah it's okay to distract me
when it's my opponent move when it's my
move
be nice to have some some silence to
focus yeah
berserk you know even an array the game
does affect your your reading you're
reading so yeah my rating might take a
hit 666 for the bits God or the bit the
bits devil not sure about that but again
like I'm okay being distracted so my
poems under pressure like way either has
to take the bishop or retreat or somehow
lose a pawn I'm like for the most part
I'm happy with simplification be very
happy hood in this line where I file
open
the baseboard is evil
it's God is evil
I'm trying to anagon that to like go
devil or something if it's good so it's
really the bits devil a devil is
basically an evil gone right all right
oh this makes me happy I think I guess
rook F 3 is ideal but that shouldn't be
too troublesome hmm let's not get too
wrapped up into philosophy yeah okay I
have to focus cuz we're after he's
coming my queen my queen doesn't have
any squares here we got three I'll have
to play this I mean this structure is
just so nice for me though those pawns
always we I file would be usable you
five will come someday oh it's it's
captain flack with five hundred bits
Hari Krishna yeah life gets a lot more
complicated the older you get
also chest gets a lot more complicated
the better you get so I'll play Queen g6
at first I've almost thought this is a
blunder Oh interesting
okay so rook in workout 78596 I'm just
trying to like fantasize about the ideal
ideal son do we need the the sole
subscriber count' thing I think I can I
can probably remove this but thanks
everyone for subscribing it's been crazy
wait I was going to show the number what
if I but they might be real
the porns wanted for the Flying V yeah
or just a smiley face you smile a V no
close oh yeah V for victory
the thing is so I don't want to play e5
too soon even though I might I was in
the show just to show like the numbers
oh my head my head's in the way but I
was not expecting this to happen like in
one day to jump from this to this but
thanks again everyone so I'm gonna
remove I'm gonna hide the subscriber
number maybe show it again very deep
discussion here how's a good move I want
to see you will the YouTube you guess it
yeah I'll do I'll do an unboxing video I
think right
I could unbox it livestream livestream
unboxing it feels wrong though - like
stream stream a you - unboxing on Twitch
wait this is a free pawn queen g5 is
coming though in the smooth
I'm more interested in mating I think I
just wondered though today's done itself
hasn t it reaches me the child is always
out doing itself I just wondered this is
really bad
position was good now yeah now it's very
questionable
it's still not the end of the world he's
a hot dog sandwich why or why not I mean
it's a vertical sandwich or horizontal
when you flip it so I'm down the pond
but there's some there's actually some
compensation here yeah but now it's it's
a V missing it's it's a left hand oh
that's nice to hear
thanks so much a KD 707 thanks for
subbing at Tier three for ten months
if you blend it
I can take this wait free porn
anyone who says this isn t sandwich
lives in denial
wait I thought the rule is you can make
noise on my opponents turn but not on my
turn
because it's getting it's getting very
heated I won my blundered upon with them
one at that about to win another pawn
maybe there you go
a KD 707 obeying the rules my life horns
thinking ooh
Queenie ones running mate thing is
Queenie one is really annoying oh wait
what
okay it's gonna get insane today oh nice
Mark J Turner congratulations good job
your celebration is my celebration so I
have the calculation of the rook e8 King
g7 Queen a1 King g6 rook GA King eh 5 g
14 eh for just like Nigel Schwartz
it's either winning or losing or maybe
drawing oh there's there's queen d1 and
online wait am I just getting needed so
the problem with Queenie one I can't
really block with anything unless I play
we got six which might be the way to go
so here here here Queen D Oh Queen do
you want Queenie - all right let's do it
not getting me that at least yet
we're both trying to attack on the same
side
oh yeah when I played g5 that called fur
for g5 emotes yeah things are about to
get kind of insane
so rook g8 it's a really fascinating
position I mean it could kind of
abruptly go into some endgame if we
trade Queens well if we don't trade
Queens it's just gonna be complete
madness don't hurt me
yeah it's really nice I have Queenie to
even ninety-two probably not 92 probably
Queenie to so this is a calculation not
when I played basically p5 so sorry you
have to have four thoughts I think
there's like a five-second lag between
real time and the past
okay so Queen do you want Queenie to if
we trade King F one night here G for
here and then like rook h8 I always have
this move but then rookie h7 attacking
the pawn I win this pot I lose this pawn
but then okay H 3 and F 2 are both
targets those lines there's a crazy
position
thankfully this night is completely out
of play and not on g3
oh I have a goal these sort of positions
you should always just kind of visualize
potential checkmates so my goal is
Queens xg2
interesting
okay Oh g4 is amazing one threat what or
no it's not what is it I don't know oh
it's so complicated though I guess f3 is
a threat so let's play this just trying
to simplify
okay so I'm still not getting made in
yet I'm trying to win the pawn and then
have a past a pawn that could be very
nice
in the meantime I'm not feeling good
about this because the bikini is so
stuck so it's basically it could turn
into a race of like me queening and why
trying to me me
hmm
no increments
I have to go for this
so there's nine plus three
oh and I just losing oh no I might just
be losing Angie for a g4 is strong oh
that's so sad my nights holla play likes
winning the race
yeah there's no resources here except
Brooke f2 I'm gonna have to go for if I
type a beautiful time
ooh okay oh that's a good move
well played unless I have this move can
each - I'm still surviving white had the
better approach there but 12 seconds
left
this hamster says hello
last week was like the Dark Ages frozen
nation explained myself
it's complicated how annoying move
Oh No
I was so close to I got the winning
position there's no time
ah I tried so I thought I was just gonna
little scare me yeah so this was just
force me for light so I was just
expecting to lose so I spent like a lot
of time just coping with my sorrows and
then then-white didn't go for that
thought that it was still meeting but
wasn't dating because King h2 and then I
had counterplay that rookie Sheree was
ice cream as a fascinating position
anyway life goes on
there goes my hope of winning the
tournament I'll still try and finish
strong
maybe thanks everyone for sticking
around that game playing okay so we're
going to keep the zhurqis I'll keep
trying to play aggressively and we'll
see how it goes
I've been playing almost all I joined
the tournament when they were like four
hours left so I don't know my exact
uptime but o is opponent the point of
giving me free points o made me excited
for a moment okay oh the Dutch oh I'm at
the point where I'll take opening
recommendations sorry for that let's
play this and that a ch3 is actually a a
decent line this is like chronic sand
renovation I might play I don't know
this might be my last game
we'll see ya Boozer King leads no
increment but leads to more turn their
points there's one possible botas
gambits on the next move so just to
explain this the whole idea with the 93
is to find out of for Nagi 6 prevent
sign up for at least discourages it so
then it's it's a bit awkward
in the general ideas cyclic completes
complete development I'll play Bishop
before I also want to like develop
actively we might still see this as
classic or a cliff idea some idea Queen
f6 pressure the Knights as this line
sound Budapest it is it's considered
dubious at like very high levels but
it's it's playable like any even like
master level but it's a decent kind of
surprise opening if White's well
prepared for it then it's usually
guaranteed like some smaller I don't
know if I get that reference but I am I
in the chat I'm kind of external to the
chat
yeah with III like this Bishop is a bit
stuck too so I mean very likely the
bishop poll develop to d2 I was thinking
maybe you know just d6 and then try and
take the knight double white spawns
imagine Bishop d2 d6 kwaini 4 is always
met by knight c6 can't complain with
this did anyone get the reference let's
play d6
people just saying letters and see what
they stand for you know B is for Bishop
so if whites I guess I'm yeah expecting
that afore I'll take I'll castle so
white does control space but yeah that's
a very playable position rookie is very
flexible I probably should have taken
there when I had the chance I should
take it on c3
a 95 is slightly unpleasant oh that's
nice
I'm feeling a little bit uncomfortable
here has to be very cognizant of time
one person got it maybe Paden got it
okay 96 I still had the chance to take
but okay Bishop Bishop could be useful
on c5 as well
yeah there's different approaches in the
Budapest there are lines whereby tries
to hold on to the pond
what white played in this game it's a
more positional line where yeah like
gives back the pond but has a pleasant
position but it's also I think it's also
just easy to play for me like this
Bishop will develop a 5 to prevent
before potentially I have the e-file
Bishop e3 interesting
so I'm allowing I'm allowing double
pawns
I'm visioning a situation where like if
we trade then d4 will be just a very
nice square for the knight and then
about CC six very much don't mind yeah I
mentioned this a few times if people
want to see that video I linked it in
the YouTube description of my most
recent video so if you I actually it was
just a funny coincidence yesterday but
so yesterday chest space India posted a
video of this like h5 London trap where
like there's a famous comedian in in
India who like used it and on my stream
yesterday I also had it in my game and
then after my stream I appeared on the
chest base India stream so if you go to
my youtube channel
I play a four here Queen d7 white j4 it
looks quite nice so YouTube show more
it's linked right here
couldn't get in the chat
but it was a nice little unexpected
collaboration whoa it's a raid
it's cops key thanks Chomsky reading
with 114 hope you're doing well
cops key is is probably one of my
favorites like just in terms of learning
chess myself I learned so much from
watching cops key streams but also like
his YouTube channel it's been showing a
lot of a lot of great insights
especially into London opening I just
blender and just blundered but wait I
think that like a 4 was already a
blunder so I can't blame it on Kowski I
was really bad the a4 was really bad um
[Music]
well please straight Queens with me also
shout-out zukovsky people should check
him out
can search his name on YouTube as well
okay so if you're just joining from
coughs keystream I'm getting smashed but
the white has no past pawns
weights up to the exchange and a pawn
okay it's gonna take a miracle to to not
lose this I'm probably hsx making leuf
for the King this is really really bad I
shoulda played h5 actually idea to to
get the Alpha zero pond oh thank you
Briggs Keith Briggs Keith's subbing for
three months
yeah so they Diaz to like put the King
on each seven and not lose right away
Wow so that was that was all I of course
oh I could have taken here actually I
had to take on anyone so maybe I can't
blame it on a cop's key flustering me
let's play Bishop Bishop can land on b3
it's not good good though it's been a
lot of chess today this might be is
might actually be my last game even
though I would not like to end with a
loss in Queen b7
oh thank you new subs jo-jo marina
subbing for two months and uq kennedy
solving with prime thanks so much I'm
not sure if it's chilled or if it's just
tiredness
I think the idea okay of course I want
to play queen bee seven try and win the
pawn and take a lot of a lot of plungers
for white or maybe it'll just take one
blunder for white just move the rook
from the black Rayborn and QQ kennedy
saying first time catching your stream
and watching youtube videos like
everyday for past few weeks nice to hear
thanks so much I don't think I've heard
of snot somnifera s-- I've heard of
omnivore it's close enough right
okay so trying to generate some threats
I'm going to keep fighting as long as
White doesn't have any past pawns
which is still not the case
okay now maybe each five to Queen d7
centralized I think white hasn't move
here to just make me resign like insta
resign whoa
it's another rate Josh Reidel reading in
a time of tragedy my push-ups getting
trapped the bishop house is just no
squares thanks Josh
Charlotte - Josh I'm streaming a lot
more so cotton so calm ski rated me just
like a few moves ago and now Josh all
these like new audiences expecting or
even like used to like high-level GM
instruction now have to deal with this
the spectacle shadow - Josh the best the
best grand master chef Oh Josh I had a
question actually I don't know if you're
in the chat if you're in the chat I have
a very important cooking question okay
let's just resign this back to
tournament okay question for Josh
oh so stinks okay so I I was trying to
fry an egg the other day I tried to fry
two eggs but when I cracked one of the
eggs and it just the yolk didn't stay
together just kind of oh I'll show a
picture now I cracked the other egg and
there were two yolks inside the egg I
wasn't sure like if I should take
different action with the process of egg
frying or if like
I don't know I just proceeded as normal
and it was still edible but it's never
happened like it's never happened to
where the eggs just don't don't obey
physics let's play this move
okay we have the two nights also I
wasn't sure like if like - only two
yolks and one egg is that like a sign of
luck or a sign of bad luck or maybe just
more more calories Oh you cover the pan
for overeasy but you add you add water I
had like a little bit of water
got some steam not win some time but
further than that
so the Natanson requires Knight takes e4
oh I can't okay
I've just been following some random
YouTube tutorials
it's really sad no one no one is wanting
to to play in that monsoon for those not
familiar the Nachman scent is so
beautiful opening night Knight takes e4
Knight c3 and do you take c3 bishop f7
it's actually a very fascinating line
I'm black playing safe go play f4
yeah I have very limited experience when
I comes to even simple cooking okay this
will most likely be my last game I
should probably defend the pawn and
develop it's a pleasant position the TTS
messed up your your excellent pun
cheers Cheers
Harry 2023 from the future
thanks so much something for tear tear
one for two months okay so I'm gonna go
for I'm gonna go for some kingside the
tap involving Queen g35 and try and
finish this the stream on a strong note
queen g3o ezra is right behind me as a
reserve you might end up asking me if I
if I rage quit internment you go go for
f5 so there's this kind of principle in
chess when you have one Bishop left of a
certain color then you should usually
have your pawns on the opposite color of
the bishop so in this case a pawns
control law light squares the bishop
controls dark squares so it maximizes
number of squares controlled also
maximizes of fun so Knights pinned 95 is
coming yeah and there's gonna be another
pin this is already just winning or is
it you can pay the computer on any size
custom board actually sounds interesting
I might do that for a future stream but
I'll make note of it
I'm thinking about keeping my knight now
let's just take a look and then take a
pawn I've very close to having a pawn
diamond I'll take another pawn yeah
there there's a lot of ways to convert
this the main goal is to use a h-file
get the pawn diamond I'm very close to
meet I have six BAM oh oh that would be
a bad pre-move because Bishop h6 riff
takes h7 I mean it's just gonna leave
the bishop here
g5 kind of rubbing it in I should have
trapped my rook in there huh forgot
about that challenge okay well my
reading took I hit this tournament but
that was fun got some interesting games
wait was that g5 resigns g5 resigns [ __ ]
fibers like g5 double X slam I didn't
even notice that right away
thanks chat so I do have a few new
commands which I should make note of if
people want so I'm gonna try and do more
instructional context I have the
openings commands and I have a questions
demand so I'm trying to have like a more
organized way to take questions and like
opening suggestions just see just
basically see what people want to learn
soloing starting the chat shared by Nick
buttons they're just simple google forms
if I don't have like any spam protection
so if if that becomes a problem I might
have to add some email verification or
something but um anyway uh thanks
everyone and yeah I think's like beyond
even the people watching but just all
100,000 what's the what's the number I
have the caption great stream Eric well
maybe it went down from earlier I swear
earlier it was like one I was or maybe
it wasn't I don't know it's been a long
stream but thanks to everyone who has
subscribed and made it
yeah just been been a part of the
community I'll be doing more on YouTube
and twitch in the future
so stay tuned gonna try and like put out
a lot more free instructional content I
did not get top 3 I kind of gave up
right III finished top hundred it's a
tough tournament there's a lot of chess
I hope people learned a thing or two but
now it's time it's probably time for
like fresh air